there is something about westerns man
when they're all just throwing smoke
like Yosemite Sam style just bad bad bad
it's a specifically Western type of
gratification that I get from it and
it's entertaining this movie gave me
that the Magnificent Seven when there's
seven they're magnificent when they're
eight they're hateful
the West so magnificent seven is a
remake of Magnificent Seven this was
directed by Antoine Fuqua director of
training days director of Olympus has
fallen King Arthur the director's cut
I'm not going to blame him for the
theatrical one because it was balls
there's a whole story behind Aniyah
basically the plot this movie is its
Western 101 you've seen the plot of this
movie a hundred times before
it's what westerns are built off of
really it's the brick and mortar of the
Wild West movies there's a town full of
nice folks in this [ __ ] and his army
kind of take hold of the town they hold
the town and the people in it under
their boot heel basically living there
has become a living hell so a couple of
these people find Denzel Washington
they're like hey you want to help us
with our town situation here's some
money so Denzel goes on recruiting a
cruise six other folks that make seven
so now we have the Magnificent Seven and
yeah they're going to go there and try
to liberate the town this is Western
plot 101 Clint Eastwood has been in a
movie with that plot a few times an
episode of Firefly had the plot of the
Magnificent Seven it really did you
remember that one the house of
companions that go there the hell it did
that's the Magnificent Seven and I gotta
say this movies damn entertaining
everyone in the movie did fine for their
part but a couple the standouts are
Denzel Washington and Chris Pratt
they're the two that are the flagship
characters for this movies good to see
Ethan Hawke bags gonna see Ethan Hawke
and Denzel on screen together in Antoine
Fuqua movie takes me back to training
day and then I realized that was about
15 years ago then I feel old as [ __ ]
feels too soon to get nostalgic about it
but no it's not it's just came out 15
years ago that's a long time the rest of
the characters did fine for their part
because they are cannon fodder for the
fight to come some got more development
than others some got the short end of
the stick there is a dude in this movie
I know him as the Mexican dude because
that's all the movie established that he
was shouldn't have been that way but it
was when you have a crew of seven people
but you need to set up the conflict of
the town than the
ruining process just some people get
left in the dust however if you've come
here for some Wild West badassery this
movie has it there's actually a short
fight not too far into the movie but
damn it these guys kick ass you just
like you sit up you're like all right
far be it for me to hold you to a
promise that you probably didn't make
but I'm taking this as a promise of
things to come if this is a promise yeah
let's do it and it is a promise because
to do the shootouts in this movie are
great there's only a couple of them but
when they happen they happen a Wild West
shoot-out is it like I said in the
beginning it's a specifically Wild West
thing you can't get it anywhere else you
cannot have that feeling of the Wild
West inspecting you can but it's still
it happens on the dirty ass planets that
are the Wild West for all intents and
purposes and this movie really made me
reflect on the Wild West movies that I
like because Wild West movies now are
few and far between what I do know is in
summary the hate hateful hate oh yeah
those numbers what I do know is in
summary Magnificent Seven isn't breaking
new ground in fact it's a movie with a
plot you've seen 50 years ago and you've
seen five years ago it's simple stuff
with a lot of badassery a couple great
characters a couple more good characters
some characters get left in the back
burner but I came here for a movie that
was like all right remind me why I love
Tombstone and here we are oh [ __ ]
tombstone that's another one [ __ ]
take control of a town good guys come
inside dude in the end this movie jacked
me up I was entertained as hell I walked
out of this movie theater charged up I
will say the Magnificent Seven is worth
watching and worth buying on blu-ray but
it with the other westerns with the same
plot [ __ ] this movie does it in stylish
fashion all right guys the Magnificent
Seven have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
and least favorite westerns of all time
whatever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]